trip is like your tire like what you
wear or it can be like something you do
like how you do it like you can trip on
the beat I'm saying it's just like a
wave
[Music]
what's up G cute is gonna on the rocks
[Music]
my first piece that I had admitted that
techno was my drumming piece I didn't
even buy you today so crazy you gotta
pull it up pull up picture some lady
people see it's my name
I love sanctum I told got 200 feet down
I'm really a man to watches this was the
first role as that was given to me the
he gave to me for my birthday after then
I just started just by why she's just
like all different types not just role
in system first watch this autumn or 12
rows and white about 65,000 fit playing
will live I didn't pay for it but I
think they kind of like 16,000 your
third game use this is the ladies watch
I bought those rich Amir by a hundred
twenty-five thousand this watch so you
blow 15 it's another Rolex is a jubilee
blue face distant when I was wearing the
day with my walk book as his help me put
on the blue and come out yeah Lucario
Lynn's
I got a few rings this is my lady's ring
it's a tooth biggest lately but Ellie is
[ __ ] hard this [ __ ] really like
snakeskin I hate like pave the diamonds
inside I don't even know how many
diamonds and it's hard even wear like
this up or even wear this - that's like
I look like slime my slime is like my
fro my homie and I'm saying it's lime is
like he's like it's sleep it's kind of
like a snake hey like let's let's try
breaking the snakes through the Cuban I
might you need to balance in life you
want if you want to put a head on there
put like two little heads he did he put
too little it's right here this is my
Thorin like a prince and I'm saying they
got Palmas and he got like a good kid
like Ringo Holloway in the middle widen
roads
he's qutilat' freshwater the rose to go
to the freshness he brings about 3000
and this one spot like 15 - 5 7 teen
times this one almost went down de
Lorean they glass and I'm a got a glass
I just put on my latest single car one
car your hair like my charm you gonna
pee start over like this cellphone my
car
I didn't even design it but it was hard
I proved it
my smile ain't my custom piece dripping
jam under the water I really meant it
but I did it when I have a first guy
deed and they told me that I was
supposed to like a whole title they say
drip on one and they say Oh
they say drown last get a really cool
trick which are 15,000 each 15 30 to 45
I just got this le he was blowing like a
love detail my other cubed snake I got a
Cuban with some snakes going through he
know how I was gonna like really be when
I started wearing it
so just to learn just min see anything
like to just finalize that okay I bought
this one from our roles that ones to
tongue like winding roads this our road
this much triple cross right here to
give her like a sans hand all the way
you beat the EE as it shook triple cross
what's better than to yeah they don't
lose his value thoughtful V if I went
down I was probably anything like it
yeah I can go right back to my to Ellie
and say hey give me a hundred twenty
five thousand he's gonna give me better
should this might go up especially out
for my singles I put a Russian airplane
I know that I know the price of my goal
I got some stuff I can let a type of
ring I wanna get away it it's hard yeah
yeah I probably pull back up bring it to
our net when I get it my name is gonna
appreciate try having me GQ
you